just going back to Legally Blonde there
was a thing last year you must when it
hit the headlines President Trump he
made the commencement speech yeah and
then it turned out it or what a strong
resemblance to Elle's
graduation speech it was all over the
internet now is yeah maybe a son Jimmy
yeah if you haven't seen it it's sort of
unbelievable we'll just show them the
thing that we take our next steps into
the world you must go forth into the
world it is with passion passion courage
of conviction courage in your
convictions in strong sense of self be
true to yourself
[Applause]
no I always pull down YouTube rabbit
holes and I missed that it's true he is
better when he sticks to the script know
how that happened there were DZ just a
fan of the film is just a big fan
you
[Music]